Up to this point in the unit, we've been talking about very, very structured graphs,
very clean and organized graphs--things like chains or rings or grids, hypercubes--
that have a great deal of structure, and they look very different from the kids of actual
social network graphs that you see in the wild.
Regular graphs tend to have little bits of clustering in them
and some people who are more sparsely connected to some other cluster,
and they start to look a little bit more randomly generated
or at least not generated according to a very simple, straightforward rule.
It's worthwhile to think about some different ways of randomly generating graphs.
The classic kind of randomly generated graph that's been studied in the mathematics literature
is generated according to what's called the Erdős–RÊnyi model.
Let me say a little bit about that now.
We start off and we imagine we have some graph with n nodes
or we have some set of n nodes, and we have some probability p,
which we'll call the connectivity probability
and the generation process works like this.
We start off by generating a set of n nodes with no edges at all.
Then we loop through all possible pairs of nodes--i, j--
and we connect i, j, but we only connect them after we flip a coin
that comes up heads with probability p.
If it does come up heads, we connect the pair. Otherwise, we don't.
We can do this for four nodes.
We have to decide whether to connect the first two nodes.
We flip a coin, comes up heads, so we connect them.
Now, we look at the second pair--this one and this one--that also came up heads.
The third pair-- this on and this one--also came up heads.
The next pair is this one and this one--tails. No edge.
This one and this one--heads.
Finally, this one and this one--heads. I think I have a broken coin.
But anyway, you get the idea that you end up with a graph
with some of the edges including and some of the edges not included.
Now, there's lots of interesting mathematical properties that you can derive
given the simplicity of this generation process.
You can say--well, what should the probability p be
so that the graph is very likely to be connected?
There's no disconnected nodes floating off into space
or that there's relatively short paths from one node to the next.
This has been fairly well studied.
Researchers have found, however, that these kinds of randomly generated graphs
don't seem to match very well the kinds of social network graphs
that you see in practice in the real world.